evidence suggests that within a week 25
percent of us have failed on our
resolutions a month later half of us
have and then you've got those
annoyingly persistent 25 or 30 percent
that seem to carry it on for years and
we've been doing this research for
decades and the big revolution we have
now is people tend to do what they enjoy
and not what they don't enjoy you're
welcome for decades of research for
something as simple as that I'm Dr
Amanda rivar I'm associate professor of
psychology I'm here to help you make
sense of New Year's resolutions
resolutions are really different from
Habits but they don't have to be
resolutions are self-initiated plan to
change whereas habits are how we do
things day to day habits tend to last
the long term whereas resolutions tend
to fade out to make resolutions that
work you need to focus on the behavior
rather than the outcome you need to make
sure it fits within your life and you're
not forcing yourself to do something I
mean you need to find a way that it's
satisfying fun or easy ideally all three
so let's start here with behavior change
when we talk about Behavior really we
think about it in two different ways we
think of the initiation so deciding to
do that behavior and execution so once
you decide to do something how do you do
that my favorite example of that is
getting in the car and deciding to go to
work that's the initiation and execution
is maybe the route you take so the more
we go through life the more we go okay
this is connected to this or this makes
me feel this way and we reflect on those
quite quickly within a quarter of a
second to make decisions or to influence
how we act or to how we feel and that's
all a habit is associative learning
that's how we can change our own
behaviors think what's the reward that's
continuing this link between me doing
this behavior and whatever context I'm
in why does my mind think that this is a
good thing to do all that means is that
we need to make new habits so how does
science say that we do that rewards are
really interesting because we're driven
by them if we like it or not so reward
is kind of that Catalyst or the help
between doing a behavior ones and making
sure we do it over and over again to the
point where these habits form when
you're trying to form a habit it seems
really tempting to reward yourself for
doing the behavior having a reward day
after you die at first seven days the
problem with that is then you're
shifting from Habit to goal directed
Behavior or to an achievement you're
doing it for something external from the
actual Behavior which makes it more
about self-control than about just going
through your day-to-day life
so how long does it take to make your
new habits stick around for good every
habit researcher dreads the question
about how long it takes to form a habit
and it's because it's really hard to
know it's hard because people are so
different from each other the evidence
suggests between 21 days or three months
it's not like running is going to feel
any different once your habits formed
it's that decision to do it you don't
have to talk yourself into it as much as
you may have when you started it's more
just a natural part of your day and
that's really what we want from a
behavior change perspective
foreign
if you can make goals that are focused
on doing something as opposed to stop
doing something else it's really
valuable so trade out a behavior for the
context that seems to be quite
triggering for that habit it doesn't
work to trade out bad behaviors with
behaviors that don't give you the same
reward some people will try to trade out
smoking for chewing a piece of gum or
eating a celery stick and that's not
going to work because you're not getting
the same reward out of that that you
were from smoking for example keeping
track of our habits very person to
person but for those taking a more
high-tech route is technology a benefit
or a burden the role of technology is
really interesting especially from a
behavior change perspective everyone has
activity trackers for example or
everyone loves tracking their heartbeat
or their sleep and if people find it
supportive in the way that helps them
have an easier life and more satisfying
and fun brilliant but the risk of that
is we could be monitoring ourselves to
death if you're focusing so much on a
goal or watching the outcomes in a way
that makes you reflect so much on it
that you don't allow those naturally
occurring habits to form it's going to
be exhausting to maintain over time if
it's stressful or if it's making you
feel guilty or ashamed give it up it's
not going to help
I started researching physical activity
and it's really hard to keep people
motivated for a long time if they don't
consider a part of their daily lives or
if it's not who they see themselves to
be you know it kind of irks me that a
lot of the way we try to intervene with
physical activity is by educating people
98 of the world knows that exercise will
make them better in some way we all know
we should for heaven's sakes so it needs
to move beyond that we need to make it
easier on people there's so much going
on in people's lives if you've done all
three changing your behavior making it
fun and making it fit into your life
does that mean that you're guaranteed to
be successful with your New Year's
resolution some of my favorite evidence
in the habit field is we've tracked
people's habits across different types
of behaviors across weeks and months and
we found that those days where people
didn't do the behavior that they were
trying to become habitual didn't throw
you off but had no impact on how quickly
those habits would form and I love that
finding because it means we can be kind
to ourselves ourselves and it means it's
okay to miss a few days or it's okay to
give in to Temptations and just kick
back on track the next day it's really
important to remember that when you're
making a goal or a resolution you're not
always going to feel as motivated as you
do at that moment when you do set a goal
or you do set a resolution think about
how you can make that behavior that you
want to do the easiest or the most
satisfying or the funnest option out of
all the options you have
[Music]